un match de basket avec des étudiants
ont chauffé à blanc dans une salle
pleine à craquer après deux ans
d'absence le sulfureux derby ginette
auch sera de retour le 17 février
prochain ce rendez vous entre les deux
lycées versailles a été imaginé par
françois allaman professeur de sport au
lycée sainte-geneviève j'ai créé un
petit match entre élèves à 10 personnes
dans un gymnase 2004 et petit à petit ça
a pris de l'ampleur quelques chaises en
plus quelques enceinte en plus 300 500
800 900 personnes et ont après on est
parti sur mont boron pour une machine
importante aujourd'hui l'événement
regroupe plusieurs centaines d'étudiants
sur une soirée au gymnase mob aurons
avec en jeu bien plus qu'un match de
basket mais une suprématie
c'est un oxford cambridge pardonnez moi
cette référence à la sauce nba
sur deux entités qui se connaissent
depuis des dizaines voire plus années et
qui ont envie ce moment-là de de
participer à une grande joute sportive
basket
le spectacle sera également autour du
terrain au programme des shows de pom
pom girls un dj ou encore des vip dans
les tribunes c'est une folle ambiance
qui surprend même les joueurs de
l'équipe de france qui sont venus de
basket ça n'existe pas aujourd'hui dans
le milieu professionnel et c'est ce qui
nous surprend tous encore chaque année
le match est uniquement sur invitation
pour les spectateurs venus de
l'extérieur pour l'instant ginette
domine ce dernier avec 14 victoires pour
une seule défaite